[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de grands pays sans une
jeunesse pour espérer pour transformer
ce qui doit l'être pour porter un espoir
pour l'avenir
il n'y a pas de grandes familles
politiques sans un mouvement de jeunesse
capable lui aussi de porter un espoir
pour nos concitoyens
hier le congrès a adopté à une écrasante
majorité à plus de 95 % des votes
la modification des statuts des
républicains cette modification permet
désormais d'installer un mouvement
jeunes autonomes pour notre famille
politique
tous les jeunes de notre pays jusqu'à 35
ans pourront rejoindre le grand
mouvement des jeunes républicains et
désormais c'est à vous
c'est à vous les jeunes de ce pays c'est
à vous celles et ceux qui partagent nos
convictions de faire que cette aventure
permis par le vote du congrès devienne
une grande et belle aventure politique
désormais c'est à vous c'est à vous
jeunes de notre pays d'adhérer de nous
rejoindre et de bâtir ce que seront
demain les jeunes républicains vous avez
une grande et belle responsabilité
c'est à vous désormais de saisir cette
chance celle que notre famille politique
vous a donné et celles dont notre pays a
tant besoin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]